morning John and pre congratulations on
your little Wiggly sticky baby thing any
there now still waiting also thank you
for providing me with several impossible
tasks to accomplish while you're busy
relaxing on your paternity leave leaving
all day reading pretentious novels in
the sunshine eating fancy waffles I
don't have a lot of data on how exactly
to take care of a newborn child but I
figured something like that so yeah I'm
happy to fix all the world's problems
while you're busy cuddling with your new
baby and well-rested luxuries thinking
of all the world's problems a few weeks
ago I made a video that highlighted some
of the pretty dramatic changes that
humanity has enacted upon the earth I
made that video because I wanted to get
people a more complete picture of how we
impact our planet and maybe inspire some
people to help and in that I think that
that video miserably failed it was
overwhelming and made people hate
themselves for being a part of humanity
and was paralyzing more than inspiring
my brains are just not good at
understanding this sort of thing for
example we way overestimate our ability
to deal with stuff that we control like
I think I've been run five businesses
and occasionally jaunt over to Seattle
to help kick-start a Space Telescope no
problem I can deal with all that no I
won't go great but we weigh
underestimate our ability as a species
to affect stuff that we feel like we
can't control individuals and we have a
known cognitive bias on remembering and
basing our decisions on negative
experiences and not on the positive ones
like we have to have like 10 positive
experiences to weigh out every negative
what I'm trying to say is that you are
being lied to by your own brain and also
by you know Society and Fox News and to
some extent me in that video I'm a
humanity is not a cancer deforestation
happens because people want to provide
better lives for themselves and for
their families rivers run dry because
we're irrigating crops so that children
don't starve the amazing thing for me
that humans are constantly solving these
huge problems and we never notice that
we do it we never celebrate disasters
haven't all at once
successes happen slowly and gradually
and they are interrupted by disasters
but they continue despite that this is a
graph of the health and wealth of every
country in the world from 1900 to 2011
every country is better off in fact some
countries in Africa are doing better and
now than the United States was in 1900
everything happens I think that we look
at a graph and the graph shows something
increasing whether it's like climate
change or oil use or deforestation and
there's a
ask your point somewhere at the top and
that grass gonna get there maybe in ten
years and we think we have ten years
left to live on the earth usually we
adapt in capitalism adapt and technology
adapts in my god even Congress adapts we
consistently every single year avoid the
apocalypse not because there is one
single super hero this isn't a
television drama because we do things
together do these things as activists
and chemists and engineers and
physicists and poets and songwriters and
writers and politicians and even
bureaucrats we are the superhero
none of us individually but all of us
together I drove to Seattle to the
Museum of Flight to help planetary
resources launch their Space Telescope
Kickstarter was inspiring unsurprisingly
but maybe for surprising reasons wasn't
just that you know people are going to
band together in crowd fund a freakin
Space Telescope but also it was seeing
the artifacts of great projects that
humanity has enacted together and
meeting people extremely smart and
dedicated people who are working their
butts off to make sure that humanity
continues its path toward a more
prosperous future for the majority of
people the majority of the time and it's
not just those super smart people it's
all of us all of us working together to
make the world work it turns out that we
are very good at solving problems but
they do not solve themselves what I've
realized is that working hard to create
a better future does not come from a
place of wanting to avoid the inevitable
apocalypse but instead it comes from a
place of optimism and it turns out that
somehow there are a tremendous number of
things to be optimistic about and that's
pretty great John I will see you or
potentially someone else if you have a
baby on Tuesday
you